pft on yahoo sports peter king mike
florio all the big news in the nfl and
coming out of week two the biggest news
the long list of injuries an incredible
array not just of injured players but
injured
star players too many to mention in the
five minutes we have but here's the key
peter let's spin it forward which teams
are most impaired by the injuries that
have unfolded so far this
season the san francisco 49ers mic
without any question as we sit here
after two weeks of the season i would
argue that eight of their 10 most
important players i'm not saying best
players whatever but i would say eight
of their 10 most important players
have are either out for the year or have
something that could keep them out of
this week's game in the meadowlands on
their favorite turf against the new york
giants
and and i mean if you look at it mike
let's just say you want to take out eric
armstead and mike mcclinchy let's just
say
i mean
every other place across the board on
this football team
from raheem moster to
jimmy garoppolo to debo samuel
um
to to the other side of the ball
obviously to bosa to sherman you look
everywhere in my opinion
this is the team that has been wounded
uh the most seriously and and again
mike we might be looking at
the best
division
in recent years
in the nfl top to bottom
and there is no guarantee whatsoever if
the team we thought had a good chance to
be number four in the division goes to
number one in the division the 49ers in
week one and beats them
there's no guaranteed wins for the 49ers
even if they're healthy you know for the
whole year and so that's why i think the
49ers are the team most grievously
affected by the injury bug
the best news for the 49ers for the nfc
west this year they take the tour of the
nfc east and the afc east which actually
raises the possibility of all four nfc
west teams making it to the playoffs
which would be nuts but with a third
wild card spot it's possible
the one injury that i think limits their
chance to get back to the super bowl i'm
not going to write them off from a
playoff berth yet but the nick bosa
absence there's no one to replace him
they're you're not going to bring in a
pass rusher of nick bose's quality sorry
ziggy answer there's a reason he was
available in late september nick bosa
was the difference maker last year and
without him
it's going to expose a lot of stuff on
the back end that was covered up last
year by that fierce pass rush so it's
going to be harder for the defense which
makes it harder for the offense but i
still think they're going to be okay
they're just not going to be as great as
they were last year also look at the
broncos to have drew lock out for
several weeks and cortland sutton out
for the year that hurts a team that
looked to have an offense that was ready
to explode and now we have to ask the
question can do dru locks stay durable
he had a wrist injury last year that
limited him to five games now he's got
the shoulder injury you've got to find a
way to avoid contact and if you take the
hitch you've got to find a way to keep
going two injuries in two years not a
good sign for drew lock
and you know the last team look i think
the jets are the worst team in football
but at some point okay
they become non-competitive with all of
the skill position injuries they have
you know le'veon bell hadn't been great
for him but their the injuries to their
receiver group
it's it's deadly and so that really
limits you getting an answer on sam
darnold and beginning to raise the
specter of trevor lawrence with the jets
if the jets indeed have the first pick
in the draft it's unfair
but it will raise that specter
that really was one of the most amazing
developments this weekend peter the fact
that the 49ers had all those injuries
and still beat the jets
31-13
not a good look for the new york jets
all right that's it for pft on yahoo
we'll see you next time thanks as always
for a few of your minutes and enjoy your
day
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports